good morning.
Thank you all for joining in we
welcome you to the joint
informational hearing that
California's wine that.
Industry ended at from this is
the Senate select committee on
wine in the assembly select
committee on wine is well on
behalf of the assembly woman and
we are curry in sooner dot. We
could not be more grateful you
join us on this glorious rainy
morning.
And we also could be more
excited to be able to be in the
city of Hillsboro. Where the dry
creek?
Announcer ballots converge on
the Russian river.
We want to say thank you first
saw to the city of Hillsboro at
for hosting us today we could be
more grateful for their
hospitality. And end it was
honored to be a to serve on the
city council here for six years
and I'm. Pretty sure there's
about.
Twelve leftover kit Kats from a
few years ago in sooner dot.
Drawer so I a please help
yourself Sir I am by the way one
point out.
Very fitting tie bad at the
senator has on he wins best
tight contest right to look at
that up full of Cork.
No I like it Sir thank you so
much.
Pacey their ego.
I want to say thank you to send
a co chair died.
In assembly woman I chair a at
we are curry for all the great
work on agricultural or in wine
issues throughout this great
state they really are fantastic
partners.
A today's panels are about to
cover crucial topics
facing the wine community the
first two panels will cover the
devastating fire storm that tore
through the North Bay last fall.
I in the recovery were all
working together on even as we
speak.
And while the grape harvest in
much of the wine industry was
fortunate enough a to largely
escape it.
Extensive damage during the
fires there've been numerous
repercussions since.
Sunday will mark the six month
anniversary since the fires
and while significant progress
has been made on the community
clean up.
It we are just about complete
by the way the long term impacts
are still being realize.
And while we begin to work
towards rebuilding residents are
still displaced structures are
still gone and there are still
many unknowns.
One of the largest impacts the
fire's had on the wine industry
have to do it tourism.
It was a very tough fall for
most of our area.
Now here's.
The a.
The country the contrast many
hotels are actually full right
now.
But their full with families
who'd been displaced by the
fires and workers who have
traveled to the North Bay
seeking employment.
And while this is good news for
the industry.
I it is an extreme challenge for
those families who have been
displacing lost their home.
For the two thousand eighteen
year to date were seen hotel
occupancy rates up by an average
of about seventeen percent. And
will likely remain this way for
quite sometime wow this is
generally good news. There is a
long term concern since the
increase is due mostly to
displace residents and workers
and not visitors.
It's not a county airport is
also seen a significant uptick
after a pretty significant loss
after the fires.
A sigh seventeen percent
decrease in customer traffic
during the month of the fires.
But February they actually
signed eighteen percent increase
compared to last year.
The biggest area of worry thing
for all of us is customer
perception.
As you are here today there are
still lingering misperceptions
regionally nationally in
throughout the world.
But what wine country looks like
after the fires.
But the story we want to tell
the world today is that our
communities are open. And we're
coming together like never
before were open for business
there hasn't been a better time
to be a to visit our region.
You hear about the inspiring new
creative initiatives today have
been launched or will soon be
kicked off welcoming folks back
to cinema. Napa lake in
Mendocino counties
we're looking forty hearing from
our panelists and all in
attendance but how we can better
serve their efforts. And now we
can let the world know the
welcome mat is out.
Well also be talking about water
now once a thank you to the semi
woman senator for their work on
this issue particularly.
And will be focusing on water
supply issues for the industry
in our communities.
An extra out may not be this
year or next but we know it will
be coming and we need to be
fully prepared.
California's wine country wine
community have truly been
leaders on water smart farming
and we're gonna be hearing from
some of those leaders here toda.
I only want to say thank you to
the wine institute for their
help with organizing today's
hearing. A these committees have
long been dedicated to working
hand in hand with the wind
community and all of us look
forward to the continuing
partnership.
So without further ado I'd like
to turn it over to our co chair
senator Dodd with a special
presentation then we're gonna
turn the floor over. To the
chair woman someone out we are
curry. Sinner dot.
Good morning everybody in thank
you us I'd like to thank god my
colleagues.
Center McGuire assemblymember
Aguiar curry this is a great
partnership that we've had we
been and.
.
You know we've been in napa weep
and.
To Santa Barbara and that what
we are plan is is to work over
that terms that we have is to
take this all over to the wine
industry all throughout the
state of California and starting
gauging.
I everybody in the what it you
know in the wind industry so I
appreciate.
Other cooperation and and the
partnership there I'd also like
to thank our panelists up for
being here today. And members of
the audience I know.
.
Maybe this is a good day to be
indoors when it's raining
outside but.
You still had to drive here and
take the time to do and I
appreciate that very much.
We get started today though I
think on รณ and also Mike said
it but I will I do. This is
really important when we can get
at. A yard opportunity to be in
a place it's public that has the
space in the parking and
everything it's so thanks to the
city of Hillsboro for hosting u.
I as we get started today on a
positive note. Aye we're all one
of the newest EVA and snow
McCallie.
The Petaluma gap ABA used to be
a part of the settlement it
county ABA somewhat coast ABA
excuse me.
But truly deserves its own
designation
and that's the good news today
but we also have some harsh
realities to discuss.
As Mike said last year's fires
burn significant.
Encourage both the crop was
already harvested but the ripple
effects on housing the
environment. In the workforce
will be felt for years.
We want the California wine
industry to know we celebrate
and value your place in the
local and the state economy.
I hope today we can learn more
and work on those solutions to
these complex challenges.
So with that I think what we're
gonna do is we're going to.
Present.
A proclamation.
Resolution of some kind to.
Yeah.
Somebody here represent
all good.
And I'll make it short and swee.
I'm honored to be here today
and I'm really thrilled with the
outcome is some of these
committee hearings we don't have
very many people attend so I
guess the rain helps because you
want to be inside.
Of the first of all the benefit
at least committee hearings for
me and my colleagues is the
education piece.
I reset in the capital and you
try to understand the industry
better.
I've farm I farm wallets is not
the same as our great.
Grape growers so I am honored
that you're here today I hope I
learn a lot more than I can take
back to my colleagues at the
capitol. And looking for this
getting started thank you.
Thank you so much chairwoman and
thank you Mister co chair. That
would like to be to do some
quick housekeeping.
Right now we're being streamed
live to just now on it will be
live on the net throughout this
hearing and then of course we're
in the archiving hearing. Will
be three different panels each
panelist we given five to seven
minutes
we'll be giving each panelist
the thirty second heads up not
trying to be pushy but making
sure that we're able only plenty
of time for questions.
Will be opening up public
comment in between each of the
panels.
Each individual who like to be a
common and we do welcome your
comments will be given two
minutes if you don't mind is
listing your first and last nam.
Three panels will be focused on
fire aye indeed at fire in
industry covering industry in
tourism very special update
about where we're at here in the
wine country when it comes to
tourism numbers. In the final a
piece will be focused on water
supply. So without further ado
we that to be to kick it off
with the president at the cinema
county winegrowers whose just
back.
From that you wanna at looking
at the age to a worker program a
and and I'm sure she will have
plenty to say about that at a
later hearing. We welcome Chris
a cruise and then we're gonna
hearing here from Garrett
buckling he is the president
appetite winegrowers in owner a
premier viticulture is well
we're going to turn over to his
crews to be a kick* off. On
a fire in industry recover
update we welcome both you to
the hearing.
The playable chairs thank you so
much for inviting need to be
part of this conversation today
and also thank you for your
continued support of online
community agriculture tourism.
Really really important issues
no my county napa aye aye north
bay area so if we really
appreciate that. Summit talk a
little bit about the impact on
the vineyards of October fires
the impact on employees and what
we're doing now is recovery in
some of our communications
strategies so. I did include
just a two page or reviewing
your binders most importantly I
want to draw your attention to
these two. Pretty incredible
pictures I put on the front and
one representing a vineyard
really close to the coffee park
neighborhood and another one of
our pastors have lied down. And
and more in the semi Valley area
and so what these pictures only
demonstrated is what we started
hearing probably about day to of
the October fires. Was that our
vineyards and are greasing land
were actually acting as natural
fire breaks and so on that one
been your picture that I'm I'm
sharing is actually one photo
although it looks like it's sort
of to photo superimposed but you
see where the fire. Actually
stops the devastating time. At e
good news and if there is good
news coming out of the October
fires. Is that despite a bone
and economic resource
agriculture in our community
really did I have very little
damage so on the second page.
And fill flip over and as that
these numbers are from the aye
commissioner. And but there's
only about twenty five hundred
acres of vineyards out of our
sixty thousand acres of
vineyards and cinema county.
That were even in the fires
Allen so when you look at the
three major fires the tides then
nouns and down.
And the E. aye pocket fire that
was up north.
There's like twenty five hundred
acres with even potential impac.
AB does it really lucky is that
what was reported to the aye
commissioner so far is that less
than a hundred acres ninety one
point seven four acres were
actually appointed to have
received some sort of Los damage
crop loss.
So we're looking and you know
total four percent opinions were
in the fire zone and and a
negligible number less than a
hundred acres had any reported
impact our boss.
Now what I result in about a
million just over a million
dollars of crop loss and damage
reported so far so. And again
the fire the vineyards acting is
not so fire breaks and received
at least a misnomer county side
very little damage.
However as we know our just
entering by break I now with the
rain here pushed saying that our
hope and the even more. And we
are farmers are still kind of an
out a wait and see mode I would
say with the actual overall
impact of those twenty five
hundred acres that were in the
fire zone so. I'm looking at you
know both by Drake successfully
happen and in those fingers that
were and in those fire zones.
I'm more the production levels
be the same and then as we go
through harvest what the quality
of those production levels you
know be as good as we've come to
expect from IBM premium wine
regions. And here on the ninth
day. So we're still a little bit
away in seem out unfortunately
we're ninety percent plus the
the harvester ants number county
as you mentioned in the opening
remarks. And primarily in sixty
percent of our county is planted
subpoena wire and Chardonnay so
I Palmer's grumbled with the
hive heats over Labor Day
weekend. But they actually serve
to expedite our harvest out
especially of those two
important varieties personnel my
county so. I'm and then you are
at the whole west county where
was save a lot of workers were
still able to get to their
vineyards and firemen years we'r
S. R. V.'s I'm of given gift
cards to replace. Loss of food
and I'm loss of wages and we
continue to get some of those
request and and we now shifting
gears to longer term focus I
have not you know affordable
housing. Aye targeted to ag
employees so that effort and
that I think is well biggest ask
is is really helping us and
remove. Any of those barriers ar
will continue be about over the
next couple of years. And we've
been doing our trips we just got
back from New York City for
press trap and we're doing many
snowmen the cities and six
different cities for the next
six months to a lot of education
communication with our prize. As
well as a partnership with
videos with food and wine
magazine or go out nationally so
we continue now to really be
focused on taking care of our
employees in the recovery.
Options working partners with
dinner and I was going to county
tourism here on chair found and
how we get the message out that
were here were opened the twenty
seventeen vintage is strong.
Please come
the fires and and what we're dog
to move on. I'm so a lot of five
similar messages that we have a.
And that was coming out of
CinemaCon and everyone's well
aware we had quite a few acres.
Wildland acres burned over
seventy thousand acres in in
napa county I'm the good thing
is that there's only about a
hundred and twenty six acres of
actual vineyards that.
Fall in that category of of
damaged or or or heavily.
Damaged or destroyed in that.
In that judge total number so
very small amount overall.
We are looking to what but
break brings and see if there's
any delayed.
Affect with issue growth and
and other plant issues there and
I do wanna echo what Chris said
about to vineyards is firebreaks
or hearing. From our our friends
at Jack cal fire that.
The user fees are really
wonderful tools to help.
Set up and you know bigger
buffer areas around.
The urban interface as well.
Inc really keep damage down so
I do wanna add.
Highlight that and think about
how we can.
Look at further land use
policies moving forward to that
utilize.
Low fuel.
Environment like.
Vineyards and and grazing and
things of that nature.
I'd getting into what happened
during the fires.
I want to highlight some of the
rules that are non profits
played.
We do.
At the NTG we have.
Twelve staff members that.
Immediately went out and help
the community.
We are supplying a free and
ninety five masks to all of our
members.
Another of people a large and.
Getting out erosion control I'm
materials for free post fire I
was urban raising a troll fair
which was really helpful. And to
have a lot of.
Uptake from about the community
at large and vineyard owners
that came and access to a free
erosion control material so that
we could better.
And.
Protect some of the wild areas
special hunter around our water
resources and vineyard owners
are very.
A very very much adept at
putting out residential measures
at something in napa county that
is is mandatory for most of our
vineyards.
And so we had a really great
technical a group of folks that
can help I installed that and in
the broader community. I'm would
wonderful partnerships through
this fire with the inner CS in
our CD on as well as of folks.
Through cal fire and cal O. yes
everyone else at the federal
level as well and I I wanna add
a highlight that I think this is
something that. We don't want to
see another one of these but if
we do.
I think we are well prepared.
To it make sure that the
recovery efforts ago even more
smoothly.
I'm also most of the far grapes
ninety percent or more were
harvested before the fires.
And.
In so we did have some acute
challenges that.
Are are county officials and
and cal fire I helped us get
back into properties to really
reduce some of the potential
damage.
From to those businesses I'm
with one thing that we are
looking at is the the ongoing of
one quality.
Concerns we do have.
Concerns about smoke exposure
of for some of the ones that
were.
Is part of these these post
fire areas in and we're getting
a lot of feedback now from our.
Our winery partners that.
The the quality of these wines
are still really good.
You know it it we in napa county
and and most wine regions.
Never put out a product that is
a sub par in quality and so
you'll see not many of those
winds ever ever reach the market
at all.
Is I think that's a really good
thing.
There are quite a bit of a
damage.
Things over hearing from
individual property owners.
Piping erosion control.
Equipment buildings actually
quit mend fences
things like that that are are
aye in progress with them. With
them recovering from.
So I think that's that's a a
good update from around most of
vineyard owners I think are
confident going into the season.
And that they'll be able to keep
their businesses healthy and of
survive through this this.
In this area.
I'm one thing that we do have a
concern we have.
Are waste discharge
requirements.
And I think that's the ask that
it like of this.
Committee to take a look at and
we were successful in working
with them to have a delay in
implementation. Of for some of
the areas that are our hardest
hit by the fires of some of the
properties that.
Lost everything and and have a
hard time complying with these
rules.
And so we we have an ongoing
relationship with the water
board and and we hope that
they'll be sympathetic to.
Making sure that everybody can
be compliant.
And and.
Consider a little bit more of a
delay for us to get everybody
into the program.
And then the only other
additional ask.
Like always we would love that
of the state of California helps
with a research funding and for
all of our. At a different
concerns in the one great
business.
And then that that we do we
will learn quite a bit about
affects of fire and.
And quality parameters on wine
and we hope that we can prop
that research up.
Through this committee.
Into which is buckling would
like that open up for questions
or comments from the committee
before we go to public please.
You know I have like a couple
comments on my frustration
during the fires as the same as
yours I thought the media went
just a little bit too far. We
appreciate the fact that we
wanted to keep people out.
In a coming lower trying to
deal with the fires but that my
frustration was for you as well
as it is still open for busines.
And trying to get that message
across was tough.
I think that we tried to do a
really good job along the way is
that.
We're strong we're still going
to be moving forward so.
Has there been discussions with
a major.
Media outlets is like no have a
conversation with the tourism or
whatever agriculture as five
where are we really. A because
Everytime I think a lot of
people canceled wedding plans up
here it cancel the vents appear.
When in reality they probably
didn't have to do.
I think you're here poli more
for my colleague on the tourism
higher but I know I think all of
anything just the important
communication for all of us is
wherever we go. On no matter
what I will representing our
counties that were impacted it's
important to communicate that
were open for business and I
know. And we have a chance to
talk about our vineyards no wind
we're doing just out doing more
than we could ever done and I
know. And Justin are
presentations were now starting
everything it just it it helps
us to start a conversation with
an update on the fires and then
you get into okay now we're
gonna shift to it is business as
usual also let's get back to.
Doing what we do best and
talking about a great
agriculture and a great wine
hearing a great tourism
opportunities and so. I know for
us this is an ongoing
communication I think we're
gonna have to overcome those
images and what six months those
images and come right back and
then they're going to come back
in a year.
John
and so we're gonna be I'm I
think more focused than ever and
work together to do that I think
everyone in our communities
highs that I'm sense of
responsibility.
And I last comes out I
appreciate you doing for housing
for your yeah community.
.
We've worked hard on some US
senator Dodd minders farm worker
housing for napa. I'm I'm
working on a bill now to update.
Migrant housing which has not
been touched in a. A amended for
for over fifty years and we need
to use those housing taken this
time so we're trying to work on
that.
So I appreciate your to asks.
And no one should have more
discussions on those thank you.
Senator.
If you're can we talk a little
bit more in depth on that
research that.
The industry would like I think
that this is a great time.
Yet to be doing that we all
have a great relationship with
secretary ras.
.
In in I think that.
If we can get a little bit more
defined on what. We'd like to do
where we like to do and and
maybe even just for our
edification what other type re I
know you see Davis obviously has
a lot to me we can.
We'll be talking.
.
You know there is well but. Yet
some thoughts on that we can
flush out here yeah I think I'm
you know the the broad.
The broad research that we've
been looking at that week we had
a big fire aye issue in some run
our north coast counties in two
thousand eight I believe and so
there's a lot of lessons learne.
Aye in there and and I think
Glenn is here as well and can
maybe speak to that later. I'm
and you know the of fire and
smoke can affect grapes very
different times and so we're
having to rely oftentimes on on
research from other areas and
their experience with that.
It would be nice to to bolster
that and and make sure that.
A lot of the.
A private dollars have been
spent on research.
During this this.
Of fire area gets put to use in
a broad.
A broad spectrum that we can.
Educate not just our industry a
here in in California but other
people that may go through this
as well. And is very critical in
these things happen at
harvesters not a lot of time to
make fast decisions and so I
think that said that was a real
concern everybody scrambling for
information. To be really nice
to to really bolster that
information back if we can.
And leverage some of the
private and and public funds to
make sure that happens I'm so
this is an ongoing bigger
question and and I think there's
ways that we can integrate with
UC Davis. Aye and our local
farming visors to together a lot
of. That information and and put
it to good use.
What one of the things that that
I think and I I think it's
important that?
Snowmen AB.
Meant no Lake
you'll get together.
.
You know in in may be the scope
McCarty could help.
I think they have something
sooner rather than later.
Well we're what we're doing is
we're going we're gonna go here
from one administration that
we've got to the end of this
year. And then there's gonna be
a new administration
and a lot of things were what
the world the North Bay
delegation with.
Assembly member would and so I
members Levine as well.
Is working on a plan we're gonna
try to get some language in the
plan that it just doesn't end.
You know with this
administration we need to make
sure is this is not a one to two
year. Problem.
That we've got so this research
has got new to me in terms of
your hearing that as a potential
budget item. I think it's
important if we can get some
back. Does that to be exact it
like an outline of what.
Things we think is you know
important in get with the
academia to to try to get a
handle on. What that'll take to
do it so that we can make a an
educated guess on what we're
gonna have to ask for? I with
this administration moving
forward.
And. It's because Calderon
wouldn't you brought up the
technical in some of the.
New ideas that are out there I
had the opportunity to.
Here conversation and they met
with us scripts you institute
talking about some of the new
cameras they have out there that
they can predict. I'm in.
Where the fires going in the
direction and help the
firefighters get away from
whether urban or farmland or
whatever? And those some of the
new technologies that are out
there that I with satellite
imaging as well as with the.
Reigns over having now they can
predict a pineapple express
coming you know days and days in
advance to of the farmers helped
our our while water system so. I
think there's things out there
and I really appreciate the fact
we need to do public private
partnerships.
On the government can't do it
all but we're willing to I think
we need to open up. A can be
more flexible than we have been
in the past and you know as we
look at climate change and
things along that line. We have
to work sooner than later so.
I I love the new technology
this coming our way and I'm
hoping another committee we will
I invite some of those people to
join us.
Thank you so much is unknown
deserve a few questions in in
this is a sign up anecdotal
measure. At some of it will be
for the vendors as well but it's
fun to see if you have any. And
all data that you're seeing for
example like a winner widely and
promotion is coming up in cinema
county or liquid went in napa
county.
If you can talk about what
you're hearing from your growers
in regards to numbers.
And then I'd also be interested.
If you have growers who also
had thrown winery.
I in touch by traffic that's
been come in understand this is
a slower season.
But if you can just give us a
taste of what you're seen combat
coming through the valleys.
A both domestic and
international travelling you
believe it's been impacted by
the fires BiCu I'm.
Please
is Chris aghast I found a good
question great it's all
anecdotal right now shirt like
it's a blue cloudy will provide
some tourism update numbers but.
You're hearing it's really next
to be honest.
Which I think is probably just
par for course with the witness
businesses so I've heard some
folks and we had you know some
of the there I went there aye
bell tastings how'd.
You know better than ever mark
more customers than ever or even
less customize but I was a more
qualified customers not that
actually spending so spending
would be up.
And so I think it's.
Effort others a said I was a
little bit more of a struggle to
get hear me we have less numbers
it really I think it's hard to
generalize right.
Doubt
October is a prime tourism mind
for our dinner partners and you
know we suffered a lot during
the October November but I think
I am everyone is doing as you
know a fantastic job of
continuing to promote and I
think we're seeing that
individually from our wineries
are. Growers and tourism
partners as well as the
associations that are sort of
rowing everyone together so I
think the recovery is happening
again it's kind of been on a
case by case basis and I think
it will take us power that full
year to really understand. And
what if there's been a real a
real change.
Spoke
I mean yeah and I would echo a
lot of that as well I think we
do have and not really my
wheelhouse to to.
Summarize those things into
traffic but anecdotally from a
lot of the people that I work
with.
You know we had an initial
swamp of of.
People coming through and and
that was immediately post fires
it seems to recovered.
Quite a bit lot of that's due
to the.
Again the positive image that
we are portraying which really
is true and and I and I think
you know this is just an
opportunity for us to.
Make sure that we're getting
the message out properly that we
are open for business and and I
would expect that that a normal
season two. To hopefully.
Come out of this.
Okay skirts finishes and I had a
I do know my own experience as I
travel a lot but I've been in a
number of restaurants right not
announced when I was brown and
their band. I'm server songs
actually saying Hey please by
about us no cutting wind para
para napa valley wine support
them right now they're helping
recover and so that's and. Then
some of our messaging is being
really resonating I know I spent
but at first we Kansen in San
Francisco after the tires and I
just.
About how debate the gentleman
that support about so I think
the more we can say even
everywhere in the world you can
still support as locally rebuilt
and aye aye families rebuild. By
supporting one of our biggest on
economic drivers so important.
Thank you and I think I deserve
just two other comments in a one
is a legislature put forth this
affordable housing by the has
returned million in for
farmworkers housing get replaced
Joe srna funds which I think
will be.
Really nice complement to what
industries are already moving
for within. Really was napa
county of what you have in the
ongoing basis once I think you'd
be some the woman senator for.
Over the bill last year to be
able to increase that.
And obviously working with
industry as well.
And I think I don't use a fire
cameras I think. Whether it's
that it would be they someone
brought up some really good
points.
And I was just talking with
senator about the system can't
water agencies very interested
in these fire cameras Annie it
deployed them in San Diego
county.
Where?
To be a protect watersheds
Soviet significant fire for
example in our neck of the woods
it's like cinema watershed.
That's can impact customers are
not just you're in Sonoma county
but down in Marin is well it's
the main water source. Up for up
hundreds of thousands in what
they residents
the sooner we get on these fires
the better. I've for suppression
so.
I think there's.
But.
There's a dual purpose these
fire carries it can
but also help industry is well
as government to protect our
water supplies well.
So without further do what only
open up to any individual who
elected here to speak on on
these.
On any of the issues you just
heard from this panel we welcome
individual to be have come
forward PC your first and last
name. And if you can if you
don't mind if you'd like to be
able to ask question district to
the panel.
I excuse me to the dice here.
You like to be a speak on this
panel.
Please come onboard widely read
appear to the podium.
If two minutes we welcome.
Go into but.
Hi I'm glad McCarty I'm gonna be
speaking later but I just wanted
to add to the issue on on.
.
Off flavours from smoke
that there is so a collaborative
movement going on between
Washington state Oregon state
and.
University of California to look
at this because it's a it's a
west coast problem.
And our next week all the flying
British Columbia to speak at
lake up.
Oaken not going to talk to them
about her experiences with smok.
Because they also experience in
Canada as well so this is a big
issue.
That I think it's part of
climate changes we can.
Right with these really wild
fires that commended artists
wildfires are wild wild fires
that do so much damage.
Now I think is a much.
His comments.
Anyone else like beer to speak
we welcome you to please come
forward.
Alright it was a thank you to
our first panel I think you so
much miss Cruz Mister Bucklin
for all your work we're gonna be
transition to our next panel.
Which is can be moderated by
senator bill died which if we
focus on industry tourism and
will turn it over.
The silly woman better moderate
our water supply panel senator
Dodd.
Intel stick.
A tourist.
Tourism related the wind
industry is one of the main
drivers of the local economy.
We no significant ever visitors
come here solely to taste and
purchased locally made winds.
This understand hotels go
shopping patronize restaurants
at a high rate.
All this generates revenues to
keep local governments afloat.
We saw a sharp drop in these
revenues even in communities
that had no direct damage from
the fires.
Like the city of a settlement
for example.
That is why it's so critical to
continue to market this region
has an amazing destination that
it is.
We need tourism especially now.
So with that we are going to
call up the next.
Panel and.
.
Well on our I comfort the
executive in residence at the
White business so
that's number State University
Press.
So my county tourism
welcome.
Clay gray gray president CEO of
visit napa valley.
Ed Chau BC I'm presidency EEO a
visit the Santa Ynez valley.
Welcome.
So what we get started that
order I thank you.
I investment thank you so much
to all of you for your continued
focus on this issue as what the
industry pulls itself out of it
but.
As stated earlier this was a
significant impact and will be
will be a long road for all of
us spent time I'm going to shar.
A little bit of background that
will actually thinks it some
context for comments from my
colleagues here and.
This really centers around some
work that was done by the wine
business instituted some state
university. That launched
actually during the fires and it
started with a conversation on
October tenth when we quickly
realized that we had as an
academic institution we had an
opportunity. But also a
responsibility to share that
some fact based information and
correct the story that was being
portrayed around the world. And
what was actually occurring here
in cinema county napa county
magazine on Lake counties during
the fires.
And its significance that are
the as an institution we were
able to take a step back and
focus on the entire north coast
region. M. in the work that we
did so all of the the facts and
the information that I'll be
sharing. Really ties back to
that entire region of the five
counties that were affected by
the fires.
We quickly realized that that
was going to be essential
because as the fires were. Aye
dynamic and we work across couns
that fire worked across county
lines we thought it was
essential that we share with the
world what the true impact was
on. The wine industry from that
same perspective.
And while we recognize that
devastating affects across our
communities we also saw that it
was vital that we share with the
world that the fires were and
much more localized in terms of
their impact on the industry the
wine industry specifically.
So. During the early days the
fires we quickly reached out to
all of the whining grape growers
associations across the five
regions in order to.
It create a collaborative
effort to share information and
communicate as we saw the story
splashed across the media
respected Nuys was going to be
essential in the coming days to
correct that story. Share
accurate and factual information
of the impacts of the fires on
the wine industry and also
forecast is recovery.
So we moved quickly to.
Collect data working across.
All of the associations
including partnering with their
agricultural commissioners with
that grape growers the winery
associations and.
Individual grape growers
wineries themselves to collect
consistent data and what we
found really centered around
three. Key findings
the first was at the actual
impact of the fires. Was heavily
localised.
And isolated.
Well because there are
significant.
There was significant acreage
that was within the fire zones
has consisted in cinema county
in his guard stated in napa
county that actual acreage that
was directly impacted by the
fires was significantly less.
Without also evaluated in terms
of actual wineries directly
impacted by the fires me found
similar findings. And I shared
believe that you have.
Within your binders that that
press release that some aye some
of the findings from our initial
report just a state some of
those figures that what we found
was that across the north coast
region ninety nine point eight
percent of vineyard acres. Were
not directly impacted by the
fires.
Ninety three percent of wineries
reported as unaffected. By the
fires and that ninety nine point
five percent of the total crop
value was realized in two
thousand seventeen.
Which was in direct contrast to
the way that this was portrayed.
In the media.
Which leads to our second he
finding which was that the most
significant and lasting impact
of the fires has actually been
is visitor slowdown due to the
images portrayed in the media.
We recognize that the media was
arm was moving quickly to deal
with a dynamic.
Situation that information was
challenging to get to
communication was compromised
that and many times they were
doing their best to share what
they know. Unfortunately it led
to.
As we all know a very negative
and I'm. Escalated image
that was portrayed.
So I am we have seen that as one
of the most M. significance as I
said and lasting impacts on
things.
Securely challenging about the
visit
a slowdown is in fact in fact it
is packed and wineries that work
outside of the fire zones
directly so really stretched
across the entire region.
Which then leads to our third
key finding which was that while
the impact was immediate and
significant.
That we also saw the recovery
did to start relatively quickly
I am and as soon as November we
were starting to see. Visitor
traffic return and we also did
see significant increases in
terms of direct to consumer
sales and tasting room sales
that helped offset. Dot slowdown
one of the challenges is that
October being the single most
significant month in terms of.
And Suma traffic and direct to
consumer sales for the wineries.
We lost those sales and those
will not be recovered we then
face the challenge of recovery
during some of them slowest
months of the year. So what
we're seeing numbers month sees
me year over year.
Begin to equalize and even
improve the challenges that we
will never fully regain the
sales that we lost in October
and that has been a lasting
impact on our industry and
that's one of the things that
we're seeing wineries.
Engrossed today struggling with
to overcome.
As are pulling out of that.
At replying further into the
second quarter of the year in
two thousand eighteen we're
starting to see these numbers.
Continue to improve and
normalize.
Share.
Again more based on anecdotal
data since we don't have firm
data gets in terms of actual
winery visit numbers what we did
see was it through the first
quarter of the year. Our weekend
traffic was starting to pick up
however midweek traffic
continued to be slapped. And how
was buried UMD winery to winery
but overall for the industry we
have seen as a much more gradual
recovery then we would have
liked.
I am pulling at as we're now
stepping into April we're seeing
those numbers continue to
increase.
Industry events have been mixed
some have been.
Consistent with prior years
others have been down.
Fortunately we are seeing
individual sales increase.
Over also there's a slight
uptick in terms of the average
purchase but if that's we're not
saying that necessarily enough
to.
Completely cracked and cover the
shortfall that we experienced at
the end of last year.
We see individual cells apology
of anti individual act yeah yeah
individual customer sales
forcing the average. Is a direct
sales in the tasting room
certain thank god.
Correct.
Harm and so I applied to
conclude with.
.
With twenty out that we're now
behind interface to about
studying which is going to be a
focus on really.
Evaluating and most importantly
educating and communicating
around the impacts of smoke and
fire on wine we recognize that.
When there is a potential
exposure for our industry in
terms have a misperception
around a quality.
Story of wines from the two
thousand seventeen vintage and
we see that the most significant
wider I'm upset that will be
through educating trade media
and consumers and doing that
from an industry perspective. So
we've started a partnership with
UC Davis and were working hand
in hand with professor David
Bach and Karen block at UC Davis
to put together a panel. Are.
Both makers and growers to work
with.
Evaluating some of the
assessment protocols and make
recommendations back to the
industry in terms of ways to
manage and work with aye any
smoke tainted or smoke affected
winds but then most importantly
put together talking points and
education points. That we can
share with the media and trade
as we head into the back half of
this year. In order to again
make certain that the correct
story an image.
but fires
a lot of first responders state
government.
People that were responding.
County government in city
government I know he's gonna
hate me for doing this but I'd
like to recognize.
Fire chief Tony Gardner from
the city of Santa Rosa is no
finer representative.
Of the of our first responders
this guy was absolutely amazing.
Every step of the way during
this and I give a lot round of
applause.
I just knew who think I'm glad
you said something because why
some I got chills because got
all the one of the things he'd
done during the fire so thank
you very much Tony.
I just ask one quick question
who were that UC Davis professor
working with you working with
doctor David block he's the head
of the viticulture department
and can block and also and you
know over Meister.
And.
We are putting that study
together so I did want to follow
up on the comment and they are
absolute in looking for funding
and we are preparing an overview
of what's the is specifics will
be of the projects that would
require funding. We do have some
private funding but support and
engagement with our public
partners would be.
That would be fantastic as we go
forward in so we can certainly
follow up with you with
additional detail in coming
weeks. We all think.
Okay.
Thank you so much are good
morning everyone Claudia Vecchio
from Saddam a county tourism.
And I come at this a little bit
on different a perspective I
started my job on November first
so much of what I talk about was
this extraordinary team it's no
McCarty tourism.
That were there during the fires
and really I think. I'm
displayed at Nick incredible aye
tenacity in getting this aye
that crisis communications of
program underway right when the
fires began so. My hat's off to
this team that was in place
before I got there and.
You know initially I during the
fires there was a.
There's a firm fairly standard
crisis communications protocol
bad to organizations will go
through in this this is a say
this team did this I think as
well as can be done. Aye
originally you real we shot off
all of our communications all of
our marketing and to really.
Hunker down and did what we
could to support community to
support those who were. Armed on
the front lines and so. One of
the first things that we did was
just.
Two I thank those who did a.
Support us fired cruise all of
their individuals and so we went
into a community relations mode
right from the get go. Aye to
ensure that we did everything we
could for our community
certainly many of those are
employed in the tourism industry
one out of tens number county.
Residents are employed in the
tourism industry so was
important for us to work with
our our teams but then as has
been mentioned as several times.
Once the fires were contained
once we knew that that I'm.
Immediate need was over it was.
Absolutely imperative that we.
Out there were open for business
message we did this in a number
of ways. Out we did have posters
of one out and you'll see this
said to a number of different
properties around. Cinema county
our boat through our incredible
work with the media in and
social media and we did actually
I think for the first time ever.
A joint add with our friends and
napa valley down in the snow but
and those of.
San Francisco Chronicle.
We really show that this whole
region was open for business and
that as a message we tout to
today.
So.
Yet also marketing organization
it is imperative for us to I
work with our partners work with
our industry we also bet
tremendous support from our
friends at visit California. The
state why tourism agency they
did a and a band called grateful
table on the cinema napa. County
border and brought in great
chefs like Tyler Florence and
others to show that I'm again
that I might just number county
in napa valley still remain this
pristine and beautiful location
that it had. Has always been and
always will be.
But the perception certainly did
arm persists then Annette to
some extent certainly does today
as well so we.
We.
This is the meeting planner
audience we so our major hotels
through this way and so we
didn't center will always have a
cash incentive for meeting
planners coming into cinema
county.
But we added an additional
incentive but allowed them a
chance to get back to the fire
relief efforts.
And.
Today that owe we we found
about seven meanings that have
booked in cinema County
specifically because of this
incentive at night given back
about twenty two thousand five
hundred dollars to that. On to
the fire relief efforts so good
on the meetings community it as
is been mentioned before. The
industry has supported snow my
county and I suspect that all of
us here in in. Extraordinary way
aye we are always a
collaborative.
Industry but in it but during
this time whether it be they and
you get the our friends at. The
San Francisco travel or meeting
planners or I with the U. S.
travel association of is a
California everyone is
supporting what we're doing and
it's been a tremendous
outpouring I in that way.
We did a pleased with it to
preserve research during this
because perception and travel is
everything perception is reality
and. Also we did I I could
superb research of eight hundred
consumers around the country an.
That the the results were heart
warming that in that are people
who knew Saddam a county people
who had heard of cinema county
where they'd been here or not.
Wanted to come the cinema county
in a large part.
Because they wanted to sports
know what county is but
mentioned and. In the purchasing
Y. another's other entities but
from my son a more organic
tourism's standpoint they wanted
to come. To this place since we
are we are seeing bad and that's
how we a messaging our
advertising to is to come back
to this place that you know when
you live. And it's been.
I think fairly successful.
And the other piece of research
we did was local because.
As.
As senator McGuire mentioned we
have this.
Odd complexity happening in the
industry right now
they benchmarks that we
generally use for success are
hotel occupancy and number of
different inside baseball kinds
of. A measure as we isn't in
tourism but. Aye those key
hotels which are primarily those
along the run around corridor
and what we call flag hotels
those that are associated with
the brand.
Are showing tremendous.
Results eighteen year over year
as was mentioned were up.
Depending
still tremendous presn
business there so we are
starting up a program that we
are calling the cinema county
explorer. And this aims to get
people out of those without a
bet or so at there are several
visitor centers throughout
cinema county. And people will
go to those visitor centers and
get a stamp.
This is a lot like a normal
passport program but you go to
these visitor centers and get a
stamp at the visitors center ba.
They have on your list of the
entities available in the area
there's also would. Really.
It's not a great detailed will a
map on the back but. Budget aye
it with two stamps you gonna
campus bag going of these lovely
so Madonna canvas bags.
And then the.
For everyone of every stamp you
get then you can enter into thea
evaporate a little bit but we
are monitoring those all the
time this will come as a
surprise to anybody and we are
where constantly working. To
generate business whether it be
through group as a sort be
through and individual travelers
I've read you know.
I would just came back from
Australia of lots of us are
doing international travel is
that time of the year. For a big
travel shows.
And I was asked a lot about
fires and obviously Australians
are very familiar with wild
fires and I was always.
Great opportunity to dispel
these Mets.
We also had people in Germany it
would another travel show may
never got a question all about
the fires so really seems to
depend. On where the world you
are and what is happening at
that time there so. Out we
continue to be very high.
Cognizant about the issues that
are are impacting our business I
would say for the asking as as
everyone has probably mention is
housing and from my standpoint.
It's housing and yet we continue
to hear the stories of families
who are frustrated by their
interaction with insurance
companies and with other
entities that are helping them
rebuild.
I tell you.
We can say we're open are exhaue
are frustrated.
That's the experience our
travelers remember.
And that breaks my heart because
snow la county.
Spirit of cinema county.
The creativity of our people are
tenacity and resilience that's
what makes this place so
extraordinary. And to not allow
our visitors to see that. Is a
shame.
So I appreciate the time this
morning and certainly will
answer any questions I know we
we had a short period of time
lots to talk about that thank
you.
Well thank you very much Claudia
and it's a.
.
The I can't imagine taking on
that job three weeks after the
fire started and that's pretty
amazing it looks like a. To me
that they got the right person
for the job well done.
Our next speaker is.
Clay gray re the.
One and only president CEO of
visit napa valley at a close
personal friend clay. Welcome.
Thank you bill nice to be here.
A lot of the things that
Claudia talked about are similar
with that napa valley so I'm not
gonna repeat.
Those things.
But just to sort of augment
what she talked about in terms
of we did do a full page ad
together. That went into their
chronicle but also to the.
.
As.
What's the name of the paper
here bad the.
Yeah I press Democrat thank you
very much. And also.
From to.
That register in napa and also
to was Sacramento. In people
have this feeling that.
We hate each other as a
destination and that's just.
It's not true and Claudia.
Put it very well and I think
it's it's kind have. An
analogous to the wine industry
the wine industry actually works
pretty well together and it's
the same thing and destination
our marketing and that we've
always had a really good
relationship believe since we
got started in the modern era of
visit napa valley.
So when the fires first started
and I can't talk about any of
those. In your things.
Garrett did that really well.
But the very first morning
after the fires we made a
decision to a open are welcome
center which is.
Beautiful place.
And some of the people without
it wouldn't make any sense but I
may tremendous sense because not
only were there are locals who
didn't have power and you know
what was going on.
But there were also many
visitors and.
The valley we actually got
about five hundred people per
day for the first two days and.
I it was it was a boon for them
to be able to have somebody to
talk to a person to person. We
also then got very involved with
the.
Our home page on the website
was all about what was open
what's not open what people can
do what people can't to in the
in that in that first week most
people just where ready to go.
As fast as they could but that
changed over.
A period of. Weeks.
We we were very involved with
the government entities we are
very involved with the media up
we were in very very involved
with all kinds of.
Community relations
organizations. Of the napa
valley has an organization
called the napa valley community
organizations active in disaster
cho added is an easier way to
think about it we have a person
who's on that board. So she was
very involved in that they had
meetings every single day to
talk about what was happening
and what yeah organizations
could do Tara. To help.
.
It in the in the beginning we
decided that we could not.
We had to be very conscious
about when we were going to turn
on a.
Open for business' sign and I
am sure you all remember but
about three years before this we
had the earthquake.
With the earthquake it was easy
to say open for business because
especially from a tourism
standpoint the vast majority of
the impact out from the
earthquake was in downtown napa.
Including a bit our building
where our offices are
unfortunately.
By Trevathan was closed and
that was really the only winery
that was impact and none of the
hotel a couple hotels where.
Impacted by.
Water from.
Fires Brinker sprinklers going
off but otherwise it was the
same thing as it ever was and so
we've got to turn on open for
business. That time probably the
fourth day after it happened an.
But we were comfortable doing
that this time and it turned out
that I think we.
We're on the right track even
though some of our partners.
Were very unhappy about the
first a communication that we
did in our.
Way which was
another.
Full size that in those same
papers that didn't say a word
about coming back to the napa
valley it was all about
supporting the.
First.
People who came in first and
helped everybody it it talked
about people who lost their
homes Todd talked about having
sympathy to people who were in
the valley at the time at but it
didn't say anything about coming
to visit. And.
We we still think that was the
right thing to do at the time
and I think if we look back and
we see what happened a week or
so later when the whole city of
Calistoga. Got evacuated for
three nights it was definitely
the right decision had we.
Turn on the open for business
that.
Sign at you know two days
earlier Calistoga would have
been.
Open for two days and then it
would have been evacuated and so
that would have been a horrible
message to send to people.
And it was also very difficult
for us to decide a we we
couldn't tell where the fires
were gonna go gunfire people
couldn't tell where it was going
to go. And we also couldn't tell
what was gonna happen with air
quality so. Yeah into being ten.
About eight days after.
That first meeting that we have
with our board and.
We then went live with a open
for business we did another ad
that was much more forward about
coming to visit the napa valley
we even talked about the
importance of tourism and now.
If people want to help the best
thing that they can do is to
come and stay overnight and it
was at that about that same time
a couple days later that we. Did
the joint that.
With Sonoma and of Claudia said.
.
It was an amazing.
Effort by visit California to
support all of us they actually
got about a million dollars from
their board of directors. Aye in
extra funds to support that
efforts around the fires in and
now they've been working with us
Santa Barbara on that tragedies
that they're having.
They're.
But we couldn't thank them
enough we know there's no way
that we could have gotten our
messaging out.
In the way that we were able to
do that if it weren't for visit
California.
So we were thankful that we
have them.
We.
We we spent about ten percent
of our total marketing budget o.
Trying to start recovery and.
October รณ which is a enormous
for a total because normally we
wouldn't spend any money in
October because this September
and October always it too.
Most.
Positive.
Months that we have about one
of the things that was great and
is very napa valley and the same
thing happens here.
Is that by the time we were a
couple weeks into this on our
website not only did still have
things about what was open to
what was an open and how you can
help and. How you can donate to
it what what kind of community
service you can get involved an?
We also had over forty
fundraising.
Advance on our website at just
about every week since.
About two weeks into the fires
and so that Reyes a tremendous
amount of money.
And and did really good for a
whole bunch of people.
We're in a little bit different
if to go into the data on.
How we're doing from our hotel
and it tourism standpoint?
We did not we were fortunate
and not having as as many.
People needing.
To be evacuated as cinema did
certainly and.
So up basically all of the
evacuees were. Done in.
Hotels by about the middle of
November.
And so if you look at our our
our data.
Since October October we were
we were dead this is total
revenue for lodging. Aye we were
down by up thirty seven percent
and it's not funny but I sort of
have to laugh at it if we didn't
have a really good first doctor
first week of October would have
been about fifty percent.
Down in November we were off by
four point two percent compared
to last year.
In December we were actually up
by six point three percent and
again that's without any.
Of the crews from PGA any there
are all gone and.
I'm evacuees were gone January
we were up by eight point eight
percent which is.
Really fantastic in February we
were up again over the previous
year by five percent. And a part
of that comes from exactly the
same thing again that that
Claudia talked about is that.
You we did we do visit a profile
studies every other year.
So that we understand what
people liked best about the napa
valley what they would like to
see enhanced and on and on and
on and we do and economic impact
of that tourism at the same tim.
And have that we're doing that
right now so we've added some
questions around the perception
throughout of the fires.
.
But.
What?
Y. what was he where was I
going to go with that the.
So I'm even ins in spite of how
well or we're doing and the fact
that.
Where were on it and a nice
kind of upward?
Road.
What's happening is around other
parts of the country like.
Claudia did talk about is that
people still think that there
are five especially on the east
coast. And.
There's because there's a
magazine when there's a.
Eh.
Into to you called MPI. Yeah I
can only remember acronyms now.
Many MP aye yeah aye is a big
group.
Organization and they also have
a magazine and so I got a call
from them about I would say it
was probably middle of December
so the fires were long gone by
that point. And this gentleman
he started out by talking about
how how little tourism are
structures must be left at this
point.
And and I was like it's just.
You know I mean by then some
really good stories had been
right.
Specifically that I can speak
about napa valley that New York
times did a great story about
how beautiful it still isn't
known LA times that exact same
thing. And this guy in them in
tourism marketing and selling I
thought that we basically had
lost all of our hotels that none
of the wineries are open and and
that he was serious.
And so it's just it's very
frustrating and how how
difficult it is to get that out
so we just have to stay on that
stand that and stay on that. And
regarding what.
We were getting a lot of help
actually are the people who need
it the most are getting a lot of
help from.
The county.
Changes in permit process
saying that if folks who who
have had homes in the county
proper. Then.
And they're and they're
destroyed they can rebuild that.
With that add up to a twenty
percent bigger and they get to a
much more streamlined process to
go through to get permitting for
that which has helped a ton.
Everything that we are hoping.
Can change in a meaningful way
is that that the insurance
company.
.
Industry a group really does no.
Come across as a very.
Helpful thing for consumers who
have lost.
Incredible things about around
their lives like their homes so
and county is also working on
those things so.
My think they're they're trying
their best to do things and you
do it in a really rapid manner.
Thank you very much.
Thank you collect but now we
have shall be Sam who is the
president CEO of visit the Santa
Ynez valley. Had the opportunity
when we were.
Allen our last.
.
Joint committee on a
subcommittee on wine visits said
in as Valley very very beautiful
and.
Take away fantastic thank you
and and.
I just I can't tell you how
much we appreciate seeing at the
table with napa and Sonoma is is
this is amazing to me to be her.
First of all I need to think
the first responders and up for
anything they did for assembly
county.
Mar fire was a lot more reason
and.
The napa's Annapolis fire
started in down.
And what we we all came together
we were all by buying the napa
wine and then factored bidders
foundation board Reyes over
thirty five thousand dollars for
for the effort for napa and
Sonoma.
And then we get the fire and
then we got the largest fire in
the California history largest
though wildfire a Thomas fire.
.
We had no.
Direct damage in the sense he
has Valley in the seventeen as
value for those of you don't
know is in the heart of Santa
Barbara wine country.
Where thirty five minutes north
of us Santa Barbara? And.
Sewers we had no direct damage
from the fires.
Nor did we have any loss of
life from the mud slides as
Santa Barbara did we are into
incredibly affected by the
access to our area.
When the mud slides hit the
they want one freeway was closed
for two weeks and we were empty
you know a. The city of solving
one of our six communities a as
we know is a very popular at the
you know the Danish capital of
America you could have bowled on
the middle the street nobody
would have known. About it was
it was just devastating to us
and the access.
.
Once a free we came back.
And and.
As. My colleagues are seeing
their visit California really
jumped on in in and has helped.
I would see Santa Barbara
proper quite a bit.
We still struggle to be
recognized as part of that area
that needs the assistance as
well aye so that debts are
challenge.
And then as everyone I spoke
about our biggest challenge now
is PR.
You know in in as.
Of it.
Genma clay clay was say the nap
out in about napa you know
Europe is still showing giant
boulders and mudslides in Santa
Barbara like it's happening
still. Are we just had a rain
storm you know a week or so ago
and every news station went back
to show in the mud slide.
You know all those films and
everything at that he was going
to happen in never happened.
Everybody cancel their hotel
reservations.
And there has been seven
evacuation since the mud slides
of Muncie no.
Were as those folks who get
over race are the been
displacing course loss of life
but the freeways open it's open
in both directions in and
everybody just seem so.
Excited to say that only because
they could close the freeway
again know they are going to
close it again the freeways open
we are open for business.
.
Whenever the I'd like to say is
this that.
Is just that it's back to that.
Stability and that we have you
know we have recovered at again
as our colleagues here we've had
some busy weekends people are
coming back and we are getting
good press.
But we have been told by salary
county fire that for the next
four five years.
With any kind a rainstorm
there's that opportunity for mud
slides so there's that
opportunity that we would lose
access to our area.
So it's about messaging it's
about you know making sure
everyone knows that the freely
is open even if we have to
evacuate unfortunately some
folks. There's no danger of the
freeway being closed.
Perfect well thank you very muc.
At this time.
What questions?
?
Members.
Thank you so much patent is a
few questions.
.
Looking to see if the three view
and then obviously AB discomfort
as well so.
What were you thinking?
We would where.
We're in the middle these fires.
What were you thinking the
impact would be?
Compared to where we're at now.
Meaning
do you think is gonna be worse.
Do you think that were better
off than you thought would.
That's an open question to each
of you.
I in your thoughts.
Well we we for sure thought it
was going to be worse than what
it's been.
.
You know we've done over there
what we think I would road.
Right over was every year on
November first we start what we
call Cabernet season and cabaret
sees and.
It we. I could make a joke
about it but I'm not going to.
It it is what we call vote
their quiet season that we have
a caller Cabernet season because
we don't get the horrible
weather and it but it is cooler
and so our chefs are making up
party or dishes that go best
with our flagship line which is
Cabernet. And so we already had
all of the advertising in place
for Cabernet season when.
Up
member hit
and so we were able to do though
those advertisements on top of
what we're already doing and I
October. And.
And the other thing is that
what we talked about before
Claudia mentioned as well is
that people really love the napa
valley they love to know more
they love now.
Their wine country in the whole
state. I'm and I think we got
that message out as quickly as
we could that it you know I can
even notice that there are fires
here and people. Mmhm started to
show up and and and you know we
we targeted which we normally
don't do that but we were
targeted on the local and
communities to. Be aye against
by most of the cut people who
come from local communities
don't stay overnight and we like
it if people stay overnight
because economic benefit is
better. But we got a lot of
people who did stay overnight
and they still came from the
from the bay area and I think it
is because these these
destinations are are valuable
and people. Want to come back
after they've been in Xena and
this time they wanted to come
back to help.
Yeah I just might add that I.
It's complex I don't know that
it's better or worse than we
would've AB expected but the
thing that is I think the most
promising is that.
These
the.
The county and the impact of the
fires on the county in the way
our county operates.
Is going to be beneficial.
First long as we will now
because.
That the county's taken of a
kind of a renewed sense of
innovation and of working more
quickly. Obeying more efficient
you know they are now saying
BiCu we can't continue to do
business the way we've done in
the past because it's not gonna
work going into the future.
There is no better way for a
county.
To to look forward them they are
now so I think from that
standpoint.
A as a marketer it's
you always have to be looking
forward if you say that we going
to do it the same what we've
done in the past you're. You're
already sunk so this this
renewed innovation and and.
You know looking toward the
future.
Would could not be in a better
place
it you before either. Jumps in
you just cloudy real quick I met
we just take a look at.
Arrivals come into some getting
airport.
Seventeen percent decrease the
month of October right.
That's really scary I in one in
the visitor numbers can are.
Well.
We have additional carriers come
in numbers are strong.
I in you you have to be and
that's had but words in your
mouth but but I'm taking a look
at the numbers where I thought
we produce the. Could have been
and where we're at right now
they're surprisingly strong.
After what we've gone through.
They're surprisingly strong
after what we've gone through
and I think we're seeing a lot
of. Big up taken business travel
and those coming in to service
the issues that they need to
service.
I I think that.
It's again it's complex because
those are not our traditional
tourists there different types
of. It ugh visitors so I'm. Will
that watch this says things sort
of balance out but on there's
there's no question that there.
Their rivals are great we are
getting from the funding
standpoint we have additional
funds that we weren't expecting
so that gives us an opportunity
just to. Get our message out
even more strongly that we're
open for business so there are
some. You know that's a good
thing for us as well but it's a
it's still as Chris is that it
the others it's a complex
situation up some of those
entities with great marketing
muscle. Are doing well the
smaller entities really rely on
us so.
It's you know it's it's a
complex issue.
I had to answer your original
question during the height of
the fires from the wine
perspective we were very
concerned that the impacts would
be far broader.
Farmer devastating both to
vineyards and two wineries than
have turned out to be I think
that it is very important story
to really. Focus on in terms of
that the benefits of the
vineyard serving as firebreaks
across our communities but also
in.
Is that
there and their resilience and
their.
Ability to resist the impact of
fire themselves so that was
significant we are still waiting
to see what the actual results
will be in terms of how the
vineyards will be able to
rejuvenate. However we continue
to be increasingly hopeful that
those impacts will be less than
originally expected.
I'm the wineries side.
I think that's really a story
of the incredible resilience
resourcefulness and
collaboration that we saw across
the industry and terms of. I'm
on an individual basis neighbors
helping neighbors.
Everything from growers leading
either wineries and Reyes across
their land to be able to get to
wineries.
Wineries being able to share
generators to share my
power
keeping their their vintage
going in this incredibly
stressful. Dynamic and
challenging time really had an
impact and hopes.
Help preserve and protect the
two thousand seventeen vintage
for the most part and then
finally I would say the odds and
that this is really a story of
collaboration. Am not only on
that individual bases Barry we
just heard clan Claudia talking
about it Carissa referenced as
well or better. Across the
region we sign up partnership
and collaboration at a level
that we had not yet.
Have the opportunity to
experience and I think that that
is really significant change
across the wine industry that I
hope we will foster. And is
something that gives us the
opportunity to position
ourselves better to deal with
challenging situations in the
future but more importantly to.
Strengthen ourselves as an
industry across the north coast
we all know that our boats rise
with the rising tide. More that
we can do together to support
our tourism Kalra vintners are
growers well ultimately results
in not only a strong wind
industry better stronger more
violent more vibrant community
for our bass. Of think you know
make a very quick answer
chairing think you for the
answers and turn right over to
send the one that. I think the
other item that we're gonna be
challenge with is on the
government side with the loss of
hotels in Santa Rosa. I'd the
impact.
The Lhasa bay tax will have on
city services.
I mean and would like to be able
to see if you think we're gonna
make that up with a better off
season.
A because of the unique
circumstance that we have with
families and.
Workers in the rooms
just your thought on that.
Have you heard that each of the
hotels are gonna rebuild them my
last piece is are you changing
the way you invest. This year
ought to be on the market wine
country.
Are you investing more resource.
Obvious here talking about were
open for business but. If you
can quickly touch on those item.
I certainly saw the law also
that there were three hotels
that were lost and they Hilton
was the largest of the hotels
and that was. Also a big meeting
hotels others commended dollars
as ours spent there but.
At the same time additional
hotels opened aye in yes there's
a lawsuit in rooms but it
balanced so we are now at the
same level of hotel rooms that
we were as we were prior to the
fires and there is a number.
There's a thousand rooms on the
books.
In various stages of development
of the next couple of years so.
Are not the same large meeting
type hotels so that all of those
meetings were displaced they
were replaced I should say in
other in other properties.
AB but we are saying good growth
and Ste remaining strong
interest from hotel developers
did come the cinema county which
is
great.
In about rebuild have you heard
about each of the properties I.
I I had don't have a direct line
to any of those properties I'm
sorry to say but I have.
I have heard more Rama Singh.
Thoughts from the fountain
growth than the other than the
field.
I am not sure what the Littleton
folks who
if anybody has the inside scoop
but locked up but I.
I enhance investment in change a
please yes so on a does not
become the tourism board I had
I'd give us a Daly additional
seven hundred to five hundred
thousand seven fifty for the
year to invest in.
A cervical a fire and related.
Marketing which we are doing
and I.
Always where we are.
Continuing to talk. Show images
of snow McCarty now also people
know that we are showing you
know nineteen.
Seventy five pictures of
beautiful snow mechanic but the
post fired imagery is going up
we are going to be a launching
the new brand in the summer.
Will have a television
commercial that go along with
that so bad will. Significantly
increase the awareness and the.
.
The knowledge of.
Today.
Assemblymember.
Sure I am thank you very much
for your testimony.
First I want to just.
By what. Acknowledged Claudius
comment about.
The people the tourism industry
in that yes is coming back but
the people are still affected by
and there housing issues their
insurance issues.
I'm I I just want to say is it
BiCu we're working really hard
on that.
And I no the we have a wonderful
team here and others throughout
the state are trying to make
sure that we can help those
individuals and I can.
Sit down.
Are really struggling
and I.
It is a life when you see
someone's face and you can still
still deep down there's a lot
going on. And I think have
identified it as a lot of people
that really do have PTSD after
this including the fire respond
or so. I want to acknowledge the
fact that that we are working on
some insurance.
Issues
but isn't it a shame is that we
have to have a.
Issue like this to come about
number Ste
dealing with some.
All kinds of rules and tosses it
should have been changed bay
back as far as when we had the
Oakland fires.
And.
Some of those things could
change that
so I I want to just assure you
that you know we're here for
awhile hopefully.
You don't get reelected but he
joined here for awhile right and
to help push those I'm ideas
through through implementation
and making sure there's
oversight making sure those
things are done for all of us
right state of California.
Things really important.
Everyone ting knowledge also for
me from southern California is
that. I'm we had our committee
hearing days and just like weeks
before the fires broke out there
I. Wasn't bad karmas but
nevertheless because we talked
about what the fires it up here.
And that the leadership that you
have down in your area I'm
really respect the fact that.
First thing they did was called
many of us of that how what we
do what's the first thing we do
and some of the simple things
but we forget about is making
sure we do translation.
I'm some of the information that
we had to make sure our
communication without in
multiple languages.
But when you're going through a
crisis you sometimes.
Forget that.
The forgotten so I'm of thank
you very much and also that my
last question is for honor I
would is.
.
Do you have any debt data from
Lake County because they have
fires three years ago and I know
there's to people used to be a
lot tourism there and it seems
as though. After the fires that
went through there it hit the
industry but also hit tourism
all the way around.
I yes thank you so we did
include Lake County and our data
collection.
And weakened we collaborated
directly with the agricultural
commissioner up there as well as
their Wangler and winery
organizations.
I have met and yet one of the
first comments that I received
from any of the growers event
knows that that was. And that
they were still recovering from
two years ago. However they also
said they learned a lot of
lessons from their experience
two years prior. I am and the
the these fires.
Did not impromptu them from in
terms of the wine industry as
directly it was much more in
terms of personal property. And
to there's still struggling from
a tourism perspective and they
have found it to be an end it
there tourism industry is is
nascent. X. just down there
they're just cultivating at and.
So they have not had as many
resources as much support but
again against in terms of
revitalizing at following those
fires but this.
The comment that I heard was
that it just to put them back to
where they had been before.
Thank you very much.
So one final question.
.
You know the press is going to
take a couple hits today during
the conversation.
You has is is I look at this.
The process responsibility
really is reporting.
And reporting.
.
I to try to get facts to people.
Of of the dangers involved I'm
not apologists for the press but
it it seems to me that.
They did a phenomenal job
during. The spires and least
getting the word out that some
of the negative aspects of that.
It doesn't have to be year can
be anywhere yellow in the world
are people people that read tha.
Go read the next article or the
next article it's as clay kind
of pointed out to somebody from
from New York who called. Aye
gets into a large I'm what I'm
wondering is.
It into yes and that it's fine
because we got to get moving
here.
But.
On your follow up stories that
you try to get to the press are
they more call are they
cooperative with you and try to
get these words out
understanding and. Has been to
that very briefly yes I am I
would say apparently yes there's
been M. extreme interest from
the media in terms out of. Some
of the work that we've done the
fact that we've shared and
wanting to share about follow up
story and I do just want to say.
That during the fires they were
scrambling to get any
information that they could and
that was a part of the entire
prop.
Was the lack of communication
the communication infrastructure
that went down and the inability
I've getting correct facts. On
in order to report on them so
I'm from my perspective they
have been continuing to tell the
story they reach out eyes now
that were at the six month mark
there's as and a whole nother
way of interest in terms of
wanting to find out. What the
stories today and correcting how
it was originally reported?
That's my perspective real
quickly I just that talk to a
non journalist in the bay area.
And all she wanted to talk about
was the the positive part about
what has gone on and and how
things are going bad that I
won't mention any names. But it
just killed me and our
colleagues that on the front
page of one of the main.
Newspapers in the bay area six
days in a row on the at the top
of the front above the fold as
they say it was a fire that
looked like the whole world was
going up in flames six days in a
row. And there was a lot of
other things going on besides
that.
Well thank you all but it's as
usual this is.
Always a hot topic I as the
chair of this rounded in do very
good jobs it's were fifty
minutes.
Ask.
The.
There the time allocated to this
but I think that shows what a
great job the panel did thank
you all very very much thank yo.
Okay without will move ahead to
our popular three water supply.
And I'm excited to hear what we
have with our speakers today.
With are gonna be sharing I
wasn't that long ago when we did
our very first up.
One committee meeting we talk
about sustainability and it's
really.
Spark some interest for me. I'm
we're looking at different
things throughout the state were
guiding healthy soils. Are
California crime and an egg
network of for climate change
we're looking at the ag land
trust we're looking at sweep
which is the state water
efficiency you are the provides
a. Many for assistance for
farmers adding grants to help
reduce greenhouse gases so. I'm
looking forward to the
conversation today.
So first of all I'd like to
introduce the four panelists a
Glen McCarty.
Viticulture plant science
adviser at me to see you know
county for you see cooperative
extension. We have doctor
Michael Anderson from California
state a aye mythologist at the
department of water resources.
Erik Larsen with environmental
program manager for the
California department of fish
and wildlife and Katie Jackson
vice president external affairs
of sustainability a Jackson
family wines welcome all in if
Glenn would do if you like to
start.
Thank you.
Well good morning it's an honor
to be here thank you very much
for inviting me.
Are serve university California
actually has a lot of
researchers working on issues
associated with water and
watersheds.
.
On on three at least three
campuses that would be.
UC Davis UC Berkeley at UC
riverside more all connected
together in their division of
agriculture natural resources.
And then we are you see
cooperative extension who I work
for our mission is to take that
information.
Right to the lower level and
make sense of what's going on.
Of the research
various.
From the molecular level so we
have people who are working on
on how to gene's turn often on
to how does it affect.
Mechanisms in the plant when
things are drier warm. A to
outer space were doing remote
sensing of what's happening. Of
via satellites and everything in
between and I tried to pick.
A suite of things that might be
interesting to you because our
summer or ready for primetime
and other things are still
working on.
So I thought that the first time
I want to mention is service
real technology in the this is a
way of sensing.
If apple transpiration vineyard
in about the transpiration
basically as the.
Loss of water from the soil on
because of the climate as well
as my plant use
and of this.
Service similar technology uses
sensors in the soil and above
the plant canopied actually look
at air movement and humidity in
the air. And then using a very
elaborate algorithm.
Tells you exactly how much water
is being lost from the vineyard
and by if transportation is very
specific to a site.
Most other approaches to doing
if apple transpiration
measurements involve weather
stations.
And you have to interpret that
with the crop cho efficient and
calculator didn't.
You don't cut it by.
Gosh and by golly figure out how
much year dishing you to do
worse this technology actually
can very specifically tell you
what's going on in your vineyar.
And knowing what what the.
Soil moisture storage is to
tell you how much your gate
and this being offered now is a
service. Of.
It's been license and patented
who truly technologies and they
actually send you.
And an email or you can logon
with your smartphone your
computer Ashigara recommendation
for how much you water this week
or today or whatever you want
whatever an animal you want
system. Of very very efficient
way of using water and we
figured we could save at least
between fifty to a hundred
thousand gallons of water per
acre.
Using this technology here the
north coast this is significant
because we have multiple laws
stakeholders in our inner
surface water supplies like the
Russian river.
So it's or assn the Russian
river to do a lot of things for
us first morass in it to be. Of.
But I natural ecosystem or for
Fishin for.
Wildlife we're asking you to
convey water from medicine no
county downturn Marin.
We're asking you to supply
agriculture I sing it to supply
of residential. And business
community stakeholder so other
more efficiently get with
watered and agriculture the
better off we are to be able to
share water with other purposes.
So that the two professors
who've been working on this is
our annual macaroni and and Rick
Snyder. Who are both? Involved
in and also moister plant
relations and.
If I'd I'm pretty impressive
what it what it means is not
widely implemented yet but I see
this is something that will be
pretty standard procedures in
the future.
Okay so going that's is
especially crop on. Block.
Granted that we got for a
climate beneficial vineyard
manager practices.
We have a new concept of soil
health in the past we always
talked about so quality is bein.
Important to the vineyard and
that basically said okay what is
a plan need to grow well. And we
change that that discussion a
little bit probably in the last
ten years to talk a bit more
about soil health.
So hell takes on also the
context of what's going on in
the environment so what are we
doing for the watershed what are
we doing for.
Balancing carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and soil. And wood
takes a look at more of an
ecological.
Meaning this as well as what's
good for the vines.
So it turns out as the
technology behind this is fairly
simple but not widely
implemented basically we'd like
to do is keep ourselves covers
much as possible so owes very
much like your skin when you
exposed to the sun. You're doing
damage
you're losing organic matter
you're setting yourself up for
Russian because of the parish
soil. Of has reduced
infiltration by as much as sixty
percent worse and it's covered.
By comparison you may increase
the infiltration rates.
Hundred percent compared to a
bare soil. Of a lot of people
like the look of told swirled
regarding napa valley you see a
lot of really beautifully told
serenata Wheaton's site.
And you come up in a Mendocino
county where I've been and I've
been really pushing this issue
we see a lot more coverage soil
in this not as tidy. But it
certainly is very good for their
of infiltration of water and
water storage.
And usually wear sequester
carbon were taken carbon dioxide
are the atmosphere and putting
it into the ground.
So we figure that with one
percent increase of soil organic
matter which is pretty doable in
about two to three years. Are we
can hold as much as thirty eight
thousand more gallons per acre.
And also reduce water use at
the same time because we don't
get as much of operation out of
the water or soil we're getting
a motion of fact.
Ugh so using composting cover
crops are working with growers
to try to introduce the idea so
well how often it is of a north
coast effort we're doing it and.
Medicine known now from cinema
counties through the our cities
and the that natural resource
conservation services are
partners and.
Of professor David smart at UC
Davis who works a lot and so. Of
organic matter in chemistry
issues and myself.
Cho man dell from an are see us
in America Lancaster our
principal partners.
Another above research project
I'm working on is trying to
control isolating bacteria
inventor so.
We use a lot of water for frost
protection we have frost events
for chicken medicinal county
which is colder than.
Then nonpartisan only because.
Were higher elevation and
further north.
And I every time we turn on the
sprinklers to frost protective
Mendocino county we use four
hundred acre feet of water which
is a fair amount of water.
So we're looking for ways that
not have turnout on.
And one of the things that we
know is that at the center of
every ice crystal is a little.
Ice including bacteria that.
Obviously sets the.
.
The formation of of ice crystals
and if we don't have any these
bacteria on.
Equipped tissue.
We can have great to should go
down to twenty six degrees
without injury so.
Experimentally we're trying to
control the iced including
bacteria two ways one is by
using.
Copper sprays which will kill
the bacteria and of the other
way to do it is.
To put an competing back
bacteria that would allow the
ice nuclear is to grow. So well
I'm working a doctor Stephen no
from UC Berkeley on this and
where second years of testing.
And.
Like most the time what a ride
work on disease passed another
conditions of I have a plague on
the study it doesn't show up. So
last year we didn't get any any
frost administer no county which
we the gores very happy what the
researchers not so much. But
were able to simulate freezing
and in the laboratory we found
by using this technique and
approach were able to.
Protect.
A great tissue was much as.
Three degrees below freezing.
Temperatures and so we we have
high hopes for this.
The last thing I want talk about
his roots stopped reading so
much the rich stocks are used in
the wine grape industry is you
know wine grapes are are grafte.
Of plants they have a sign which
.
Nematode another passed
resistance
there are also more drought
tolerant because you're more
vigorously using genetics that
come from.
The southwest of
United States from Texas Arizona
New Mexico and.
He's having some success so
hung term project takes a
generation really to to breed
these.
So anyway that's that's just a
real fun mil sketch of some of
the things that we're doing. I
want you know we're totally
committed to true of trying to
improve to water efficiency of
agriculture across all
commodities
not just one groups in our state
because who recognize.
Of you know were semi desert. I
Enver really dependent on water
to make things go.
Thank you very much.
Interview questions.
The transom reject start.
Alright.
Thank you for having me.
So talk little bit about what
the department's doing and some
of the activities that we have
here in the bay area. Are
related to some of our more
innovative projects.
So mmhm Lara shows up in
California.
In gray bursts.
Today being and I subject
example of that with atmosphere
covers they account for. Forty
to sixty percent of the annual
precip.
Which can happen in a matter of
a couple weeks over the whole
winter season.
How your year highly variable
some years nothing shows up on
the years?
Aplenty.
Given last year.
In the past five years as a
significant example of that.
To deal with Pat O. we're
looking at opportunities in New
observation techniques. Are both
our ground based airborne and
remote sensing.
To do that we work with.
Federal state and local
partners.
.
To not only identified the
information to observe but to
leverage that information to
make sure it it's useful.
As we have partnerships with.
NASA Noah.
I the US Geological Survey BR a
claymation.
When a federal partner side.
How local partners Sonoma county
water agency has been a big hel?
Its activities.
Have late that I'll get into in
a minute.
Coupled with
the observations.
Our forecasts.
AB because water arrives in
Graber since the ability to
manage have volume of water.
To manage of volume given more
time you have more.
To plan prepare.
And make use of that water when
it does show up.
And.
Them pulling those two lines of
information.
In to a decision support tool
that enables a water user.
To make the best use of that
information.
And so some examples of these
projects include.
Not necessarily local he.
To the bay area immediately but
is he a monster observatory.
How which is a partnership with
NASA's jet propulsion lab?
And apart from not an office
from NASA's headquarters called
the western water applications
office this is a new office that
NASA has opened.
Recently located at JPL in
Pasadena for the express purpose
of improving their ability.
To take their science.
And moved it operations
recognizing that that's a
process and not just a singular
hand off was the name again
western waters applications
office.
So with.
Then Noah and this is more
directly in the bay area we have
spent the last decade with your
systems research lab.
Working on our project called
the hydro meteorological test
bed which looks at some advanced
observing systems for
atmospheric rivers.
And we have.
Snowing radar.
Witcher vertically putting
arena that look to find whoever
Rangers to snow.
It's a key element to flood
management as these storms at
the Sierra.
I we have what we call our
atmospheric river observatory
switches.
Wind profiler which gives the
structure of the winds to the
head of the atmosphere.
As well as.
Center called the GPS Mets we
have GPS stations that.
Are used.
To monitor the land surface.
In California a week couple that
was to meet a logical
instrumentation.
It improves the GPS signal but
also gives us how much water
vapors in the atmosphere.
And makes a nice coupling to the
satellite imagery.
That only works when water is a
lower boundary.
So with these.
Instrumentation is we have a
much better view of atmospheric
a recess they work across the
landscape we get a better.
Understanding of how water
interacts with the topography.
I building on that effort is a
new project through the
integrated regional water
management program and.
.
The bay area region.
Went collectively on the last
proposal. Instead of doing
competing proposals they all
went in together on a single
project for years nineteen
million dollars.
Cooley advanced quantitative
precipitation information
project.
And the idea is to invest in
some advanced observing
instrumentation including some
gap filling radars.
The big doppler radars that the
National Weather Service
reliance were built for the
Great Plains.
How the challenge in the bay
area is topography there's?
Those that get in the way block
beams and so it doesn't look
like it's raining hard when in
actuality it is so in this
effort we're going to put in.
Radar they give a better sense
of that.
Improving upon the detail of.
Understanding how rains moving
across.
And then trying to develop
decision support tools that
benefit.
Not only water management
transportation emergency
response.
And so looking forward to
building on how that effort goes
and seeing how than that can be
transferred. It to other regions
in the state.
Look look it's exciting
information because it Lara
received technologies moving us
in the direction we need to go.
Thank you very much.
Mr Larson.
Welcome thank you I just want to
express our appreciation the
apartment appreciates that flex
subcommittees scented.
Having that apartment here today
for this important discussion.
I'm and you know it's always
interesting talking about water
issues.
Pouring rain.
We found the said to be true one
we ever during the recent
drought when we scheduled.
Public meetings on
drought issues it always rained.
So a you know we might get
through this never have a
drought again if you keep
scheduled.
I want things in a little bit of
a different direction.
.
In that we've been talking
today's from about the effects
of the fire effects of water on
tourism in on the wind industry.
Up there was also a profound
effect on fish and wildlife.
Habitat issues with in other
fire region and and also
continues to be within the
agriculture areas that are used
for a nickel.
.
You know we've we've talked
about how.
The. The effects the fire had
within a will we consider to be
the the napa valley or the.
Cinema Valley where that wine
grape growers really have the
most visual effects when you see
these aerial views you see these
long. Stretches the valleys and
those are the main stems of of
the Russian river the napa river
and you get into the Central
Valley winegrowing areas you
have the San Joaquin River as
well.
Those are the main stems but
from official wildlife
perspective of those who those
are important areas.
It's the upslope here's the
tributaries
that are of significant
importance
and in the cinema valley as well
as in other napa valley.
The wine grape growers also
occupy those tribute.
And that's with the water supply
comes from that. Notwithstanding
the dams.
But provides water that feeds so
streams provides for fish and
wildlife habitat.
Not in so we focused in the past
route are drought initiative.
In offering opportunities. To
keep water with in the streams.
That were important
I we had what we call the
voluntary drought initiative.
And we รณ worked with and not
that still any effort.
Jackson.
Family wineries thunder in your
conversation but worked with
various.
Wine industry representatives
to a tee use water supply that
was captured during the winter
months held in ponds.
To put back into the stream
during the summer months.
And we're offering the same
opportunities.
Albeit without the governor's
proclamation of a drought
emergency
to offer incentives that through
our. A rapid permitting process
through coverage through.
R. MO you process for.
Potential take of listed
species to. A do won't do what
we call stream.
Water augmentation.
Take that water that was
captured during the winter
months or.
It easier even captured done by
a well water and put back into
the streams to provide summer
rearing habitat for the
important fish species.
We have in our watershed.
What's unique.
And different from the main stem
is that.
Steel head trout.
Coho salmon utilize the
upstream areas.
For rearing habitat during the
summer months.
They need to stand the stream
for a year and so we need to per
make sure that there's cold
clear running water during the
summer months as well. And.
The appropriation water for
irrigation also for some
domestic uses that has reduced
the amount of water that's
available in those watersheds.
Working with the industry to
another individual and ours to
put water back into the stream.
Has been real helpful for us to
to ensure that that habitat it's
remains.
.
What we have now as opposed to
the emergency proclamation is
our ability to move through the
permitting process?
When we get requests.
You are to make approvals of.
Augmentation.
A Glenn also mentioned.
.
Water that's utilized during
that.
Springtime months for.
For frost protection
and that's a big issue for us as
well.
Perficient la leche concerns.
I was driving through the wine
country.
In mid February we hadn't had
all that rain and
couple weeks.
And it didn't seem like we're
going to have anymore for
another couple weeks at least
ten.
At the same time I'm looking
around and seeing.
The fruit trees starting to
bloom and I realize that we're
also can be looking at by break
in the vineyards.
Thinking wow we you know we're
rather than a real low period in
our stream flows and at the same
time that's occurring.
We're seeing.
The need to start turning
irrigation so
it's offer frost protect.
That became a real concern for
us
at that time fortunately March
came around we had. Another
March miracle aye we're probably
not quite you know back to
normal but the storm will really
help us getting there.
We need to start looking at how
do we approach these water uses
of summertime irrigation.
And the springtime frost
protection in a way that.
.
Provides protection for a fish
species that are so vital to.
To.
You I tourism industry here and
and our natural resources
that.
You are just part of what cinema
county napa county are.
Ended the same time provide for
the industrial need.
Within.
You both that that's a center
McGuire mentioned that six
hundred thousand people.
Water from our watershed said.
As well as.
.
Forum. Of three irrigation
purposes in the upslope that.
Outside of that water convey.
In those opportunities are there
we've.
Promoted a
changing a lot of the.
Winter.
Springtime irrigation systems
for frost protection over to fan
protection we've encourage
offspring water storage during
the winter months
and will work with.
With the industry to.
Enable that to happen getting
permits for storage instead of
riparian use.
Switching over to stored use
the opportunities are there and
we have MacInnes
placed
that happened quickly.
Effectively.
We appreciate the.
The folks both from Jackson
family winds wells gala that
have worked with us
to you implement.
Augmentation of of water during
some talk summertime as well as
many at the. Local vineyard set
of switched over to you fan
assistance supposed irrigation
so.
As well so of storage offsite
storage her
off streams to.
Storage
we have funding through.
We call the fisheries
restoration grant program.
Prop one.
Program and.
Is well to to enable some of
those things
the fact.
For to continue.
You made a point about to you're
cooperating with the on off
stream.
Storage.
You know.
.
In two thousand two.
Then.
Assembly member.
House man.
I had a bill that would allow
for off stream. Yellow
development of.
Out of storage.
And two years ago I think it wa.
In this it are in this committee
maybe. Three years ago when I
was in the state assembly.
We had.
Select committee on wine and
the whole one of the whole
purpose of the of the outcomes
of that.
Was for us to get a little bit
more aggressive and work with
water resources in fish and
wildlife.
Because it hasn't worked.
You have worked at all.
So I run the bill.
In it I don't shoot the
messenger is I'm really glad you
guys are here that's not an
adversarial thing. But you know
I'm I'm pretty frustrated here
that because my bill went
nowhere because between your two
departments.
The cost of doing something for
the north coast and storage was
over million dollars.
It just seemed like it was a
contest between the two
organizations.
And I what I guess might take
away here today is.
It sounds to me like you want it
we have an atmospheric river
this come through here yet all
the water is going down the
Russian river it's going down
the napa river. It's going to
it's going out never to be.
Used again so I hope that we
can find a way to.
Collaborate to be able to was
see through.
Center then assembly member
Huffman's your vision for the
north coast in my vision for
than for the north coast in
terms of water storage.
Yeah I'm it's just.
Alright I really like you did a
maybe you don't feel like you
can't talk to both of the
directors of your of your
respective departments but it's
it's very frustrating.
Well as I said we do we do
encourage Austrian storage a
right now we see a lot of.
Direct appropriation whether
it's from ground water that's
hydrologically connected to the
streams or from direct pumping
from the street
so. The opportunity to get off
streams.
Really do promote.
And did you winner type storage
of that water it offers
everything from some irrigation
opportunities to fire protectio.
As wars.
Two you the ability to utilize
UHS. As source during though.
Springtime for prospered
so
we do encourage that I do
understand that there is a.
A process that has to be
followed nam particularly in
changing from right parents a
stored water and which requires.
Permit through although water
resources.
To.
Order is state board recall
that
apartment water resources to.
To initiate that and that can
be long term it's far as how
long it takes to get that but we
are willing to walk through that
we see it as an environmental
benefit.
A in in in the how I would like
our delegation let's not do this
year to be able to meet with you
and sit down. And see what we
can do to get something done on
the because. With what you're
saying is not what's in practic.
In the watersheds that we have
years I I'd I'd love did use
that as an invitation to get
together and have some.
.
Dialogue on that's to see what
we can do to make it better in
the future but I appreciate your
time and thanks for the
information.
Yes hello more on this I think
where.
Similar Hoffman was going was.
It's ya know and a portion of
the bill I that was implement.
And then they were going to be
further steps that would promote
Austrian storage.
I that would provide executive
Mister Larsen. Had just
discussed at coldwater died
during critical times of the
year.
But and it's number county had
enhance our string storage. A
capability particular US every
years ago only had those frost
related events
and those fish kills. I think
that could have been for a.
Potentially optically here in
northern Sonoma county avoided.
And. Again I think it's at what
we say you a royal you rights
organization Saddam.
Sure I think the bottom line is
the surprise are directly
involved I am.
Right then the.
Knows that it got awkward
advocate
so hears I think our peace.
Mendocino county has advanced eh
initiative and they become very
aggressive regards Austrians.
I'm in a and it is become common
practice.
Within the viticulture industr.
We have some enhanced at
compared streams particularly
northern cinema county.
That upstream storage would be a
benefit.
With the understanding that we
need to be cautious
are on any strandings or.
Into fish kill.
The common sense approach would
be taking that sheet flow.
During peak winter months.
Storing it up whether it's for
frost or for direct irrigation
later in the year or in the fal.
In so I think that I.
And we all know in this room
this is been an issue that's
been discussed for probably
greater part of a decade now.
In very little traction has been
gained.
I'm in a this is our it
initiative that. Departments
with accuracy industry would
like to be a busy I think a.
Delegation would like to be to
see there has to be away to be
able to expedite.
.
A whether it is the approval
process or at least a plan. To
be able to help this industry.
Us at achieve what they want to
and that is making sure that
it's fish friendly and water
fishing.
So I I fully support a senior
died both the student leaders on
this.
On beer bring us all together
though be good enough and if yo.
So if you don't have.
If you don't mind we're going
to move on and our union dues
Kate Jackson and she is the vice
president's total fairs is
sustainability at the Jackson
family. Wines welcome.
Thank you for having me.
AB so I am I am I. Vice
president of sustainability at
may families winery and and we
also have fire director of
sustainability Gillian zero
today and who. Manages a lot of
the projects are going to be
talking about so if there are
any really detailed questions
that I can answer.
I'm going to support.
Anyway and I have been asked to
share with the committee on how
Jackson family winds is
responding to the.
Challenges of climate change.
As farmers I may family has
always understood the access to
water is on something that is
are critical to the livelihood
of our business.
And some that will continue to
challenge our agricultural
community I'm going into the
future so this is something tha.
And we take very seriously I'm
my parents I'm founded the
business and I'm from the
beginning there are very forward
thinking in terms of.
Wanting it to be multi
generational and so on they
understand that taking care of
the environment was a critical
part of our long term viability
of the business and so. On aye
as regards to water especially
I'm we were looking at that from
the very beginning. On since
then and we've also looked at
things such as energy management
in reducing our carbon emissions
as.
Things that also critically
important issue I'm.
Hoping I with climate change
issues.
And some of the things that
we've done that aye am that I am
proud if I.
That I'm in died twenty eleven
we grafted on I donation to UC
Davis to help their campuses
winery and very.
Achieve LEED platinum
certification and bands you I'm.
Have it I'm continue and and
because I'm I'm even more
unsustainable by becoming a net
zero water energy and wastes on
building. Time.
And justice Jackson sustainable
winery building is there now it
serves as a testing ground for
testing new technologies that
will reduce when making
footprint on the environment.
On this collaboration also
serves as a model for future
winery construction for it on
those in the industry and also
I'm for my family.
I'm.
I we've also and looked at how
we can reduce and I water you
center by making practices and
ants in practice since two
thousand and eight when we
started benchmarking how much
water we use in our wineries.
I'm we've reduced the number of
gallons of water it takes up to
produce a gallon of wind it by
fifty seven percent. On today
that is about twice as I'm water
efficient as the industry
average.
I'm.
I largest source of my name
usage is not cooling towers that
runner refrigeration system so
we've I'm really made an effort
to tackle that. Area I'm and
over the last few years we've
utilized anti fermentation tanks
as far rain water and collected
from. A roof tops for usenet
cooling towers and this has
enabled us to off that ground
water usage for.
Their operation I'm for nearly
six months out of the year so
that's something that.
That has been working very well
and the second largest source of
water usage and many very
wineries is the barrel washing
process. On and as a result
we've developed para wash water
recycling in heat recapture
systems to reduce arm are to
reuse water and reduced on the
water usage in barrel washing up
by up to eighty percent. And our
continuing to trial and those
and aye on a greater basis
throughout our organization and
I'm hoping that that will help
us and continue to meet our
goals and. I have I'm reducing
our water usage for their. On
aye latest innovation Chau is wm
say capture and reuse para
watched water.
Hopefully up to ten times I'm
and the potential is to save
over one point four million
gallons of water annually I'm
without systems so and. When
that goes and I'm in may will
make cited a starter trial ends
on and see that hopefully
practice.
I am we have also pioneered the
introduction of U. vis thinks
education technology arm. Where
the first are wired into play
commercial scale you know and we
now have units at six of aye
wineries? Aye this
and these units aye wonderful
because they save us on over
three hundred gallons per team
fan occasions like also. On that
really I'm reduces the water
used in that I'm sanitation
process and and when making. I'm
which is critical to quality I'.
Similarly we worked making
progress in our vineyards.
Add to compare contribute to
sustainable groundwater at
levels we are collaborating I'm
with the resource agencies and
doctor Philip assigned. To
implement UC Davis developed
recharge on groundwater recharge
program. And how because
recharging aquifer's in
California is critical to
reliable water supply. Aye aye
firsts on trial pilots AB ants
that water recharge time. Up
program was implemented last
year and of course.
.
I. Am I was laughing at aye
Glenn's comment earlier about
the house trial. Trials
typically are put in when the
weather doesn't cooperate we got
so much whining about it really.
AB overwhelmed their. Home aye
which we weren't expecting on.
As well how it works is going to
return what works by diverting
peak flows during storm events
and then fled irrigating the
vineyards during the by
instrument system. ABS their
menses then and thought returns
the aquifer on our first year
trial indicated that we can
recharge well above water use
their vineyards so that's
exciting.
I am.
We're currently working with
other farmers here in cinema
county to develop a regional
recharge program. And that we're
hoping to make a positive
contribution to the counties
ground water management program.
And to address the challenges
around frost water use and
stream staging needed for for
aye Fisher protection. And we
worked with the natural resource
conservation district other
growers to purchase and install
when machines to meet many of
their regional on curry's needs.
I and this was something and
Eric just I referenced on. This
program has reduced our water
use in the vineyards where using
them by up to fifty percent
that's.
I am we've also leverage sap
flow monitoring technology and
that allows the plant to
indicate when it needs water.
Aye and not tech has reduced our
water usage and for vineyard
irrigation by up to eighty
percent in some areas.
I'm.
I in twenty seventeen we
received a grant through the
healthy swells program and which
and Glenn mentioned. On and for
exploring the impacts of reduced
village and site specific cover
crops.
As well the application of
compost very vineyards and so o.
It's going to be a five year
projects timer kicking it off
the spring in partnership but
this number city and I'm CDFA.
And we're looking at how we can
increase organic matter and
water holding capacity in our
soils. On and also how we can
sequester carbon on by doing
that I'm and not something that
we think and has a lot of
potential and we're very excited
about.
.
I drain the twenty fifteen
drought and we worked with trout
unlimited and national marine
fisheries this regional water.
And CDF W. and to provide
reservoir water time to put into
a local tributary that was I'm
severely impacted by the drought
which was green valley creek.
I am it supports over summer and
some on it populations and we've
continued to work with yet W.
and so on NMCI rear its you I'm
to continue those really says.
Thoughts and seems to be on
various factors were very proud
to be able to partner with them
on that.
I'm.
We are also working on a safe
harbor I'm with and Nazarian
fisheries and see DFW to
encourage other great chorus and
to ensure that water as well.
And so on lastly and perhaps
most importantly and we've
looked at how and a culture
within our organization impacts
the what the matter water that
we use. And so on we've been
able to and. It's you foster
that a culture of and I water
saving and signed the volumes of
being very Adam.
I S..
I careful with our water use
throughout are our business on
and so I'm so we have a lot of
wonderful employees dipping for
that.
I'm.
Thank you very much for having
me here today I am I had had a
couple of requests and. I as am
I we've done in the past I'm we
would be very happy to and talk
I am with on anybody about aye
the passage of legislation that
affects agriculture and how. And
then use are on what we've
learned through sustainable I'm
farming I'm to help make and I
any legislation I'm more
effective ants on less costly.
And we are very committed to
proactive management.
Of water and protect the
quality of our environment and
so.
We've I am very non interest in
helping I'm anyway on weekends
you on how with that process.
And we also want to say thank
you for supporting legislation
that promotes programs that are
forward thinking and
collaborative. On without the
CDFA healthy soils grants and
the California energy commission
and the natural resource
conservation funding programs.
On our vision of what is
possible and in agriculture
would not be achievable and
swear I'm.
Very I'm grateful for that.
Thank you.
Thank you very much of their
income.
In the reading room.
So the first well I want to.
Just I'm in awe from what we
are doing because.
I know it's tough to do these
things it's not every small of a
farmer can do this. And.
That you being a leader is
phenomenal
I've been at the UC Davis to th.
The facility its nominal and.
And I'm really excited that you
are taking eventuality soils
because when those programs I
truly believe in and yes we have
a budget ask in their home by to
make sure you get that funded
this year as well as other
programs that. Can help out so.
.
Sometimes I like to over take a
tour.
And.
Sumar were you doing maybe one
relocations.
Offsite aye aye subsystems of
so thank you for what you're
doing it's really great. And to
all of you on that up panel
thank you very much for coming
today.
It means a lot to us that
you've taken the time every day.
This is important information.
The very well promise to take
back to our constituents I meant
to our legislators as well. And
hopefully.
Help promote on the wine
industry and all agriculture so
think.
Is there any public comments
isn't which I mean.
In bills have any public
comments think.
I five. Feels about her one mor.
Yeah piece of information I left
out which sexually.
Really important in the Russian
river in inside the front custom
programs were operations.
Activity that were piloting here
on the Russian river. And this
is a collaborative program.
Across mental state and local
agencies are looking at how the
operations a lake Mendocino.
Can be modified to increase the
benefits that the project can
provide improving supply
reliability in the basin.
And using it as a pilot that
might be leverage for
information other.
Water projects in the state.
So really appreciate efforts
going on here.
That.
Create that opportunity to
explore these new ideas in the
use of our existing facilities.
It just added on to that I thin.
This obvious complications being
candid with like when is he
knows we need to be to work with
the army corps. Think eventually
like Mendocino I'd can even as
you know county cinema.
Along with aye to carry Marie
would like to be to see county
diem Rainey's.
On end how that could happen the
it's been discussed for.
Couple decades now insurance
enemies because for a couple
decades more. On but a. Long
story short.
And I need that water supply
long term and that just brings
to the question of what you see
for the northern California
region is our climate is
changing.
Up what do you seen since were
not dependent on snowfall but
these atmospheric events.
When you see for our region
between.
If you will Santa Barbara on
north any thoughts you would
have on that sure so we actually
spend a fair bit of time looking
at this issue.
L. looking at out.
Understanding the role of
Abshire careers in their
contribution to our seasonal
water yeah.
I particularly want partly here
on the coast where Sonoma out is
not a part of the water budget.
And looking and seeing that is
what the world wants by the
notion that.
I.
Maybe the bulk of the
distribution of the character
about Mr occurrence doesn't
change.
But the really big ones.
That part of the tail jumps out
a few standard deviations of the
big events get really big.
And the ability to manage.
Across the spectrum of those
events and truly understanding
the ability to forecast.
And the role that will play en
arm.
Preparing.
What we do and so there there's
a fair bit of investment the the
effort being made arm?
As a mention in observations
actually scripts is out here.
During this event doing so mom
monitoring.
For the Sonoma county water
agency.
And I think supporting programs
like have that continue are
improving our knowledge and then
as I said with projects like
cake UPI leveraging that
information.
To feedback.
And maybe some of the missing
component is that collaboration
is allowing
the good work that happens
locally.
To be fed back.
So that it could be leveraged to
other parts of the state and and
funding out a vehicle for that.
Thank you so much of this can
read of applause for penalty
think you are right for their
work.
Well thank you all for joining
us would like me to go to
closing comments. From each of
our co hosts in will start with
these from a woman with any
closing comments and we'll go to
have Mr died.
Again thank you very much for.
All of us working together on
this these are these committee
hearings always.
And like me in so many ways but
a. Thank you so much for coming
all of you that presented I'm we
appreciate the input and always
know that our doors are open.
We like to listen like to find
out more information
I just don't wait to the last
minute.
But thank you very much for
coming today.
Yeah I to like would.
To thank.
.
You offer coming I think more
importantly that that more poor
that's.
That's what makes these.
Committee hearings that
valuable and the contributions
from all our speakers today I
thought were just.
Outstanding and I appreciate
that very much I also like to
thank god. Of the respective
staffs that.
Do the work behind the scenes
to put these on thank you very
much and thank you to.
There.
Yeah I think so much admits
chair are Buddhist offer my
thanks to all of our panelists
in for all the for hanging with
us here today.
Echo would sooner die just sit
in this would be possible
without each of the teams from
and this idea curry's office
center dot opposite R. office in
his once he take you so much.
Up for all of your efforts you
can just raise your hand let's
give them a round of applause
please and say thank you.
Internally.
And the.
Do que.
I and. Of course I think on.
This one into with time recovery
rebuild.
It we have a long way to go
whether you are hotel owner.
Winery owner or a homeowner.
I'm.
This county and our three
neighboring counties have been
hit hard.
I miss Cruz indigenous bit at
she also lost her home.
And there are so many of us they
continue to struggle and I think
the important part of all this
is whether you are in business
or. A renter or homeowner we
have to work together and that's
the important part is we are
really your entry the hardest
face at this recovery. I hear in
the years ahead is being able to
get this committee rebuilding
just want to say how grateful we
are to the industry for working
together. As senator Dodd at
mention it was pretty cool
hearing how I napa and Sonoma
are working together it
traditional rivals watch out
friendly rivals by the way.
It never had to recognize that
they did have a huge auto parts.
A seated. There we go we we
heard this for years health
right exactly. At.
But we're we're very grateful it
will be followed up here
you get all up for coming.
A wonderful.
It you're an intake you to our.
Cultures as well in appreciate
working partnership thank you so
much